welcome back to cbs this morning a
single shot coronavirus vaccine will
soon be available in the u.s
for the very first time the fda
authorized johnson and johnson's vaccine
for emergency use over the weekend and
it's being shipped out today
so far only seven and a half percent of
americans have received both doses of
the other vaccines
johnson and johnson's chairman and ceo
that's alex gorsky there he is
joins us to discuss hello alex gorsky
welcome to cbs this morning this is big
day
exciting news for all of us we're glad
that you're here so the sound i think
you hear are people rolling up their
sleeves saying
how soon can i get the shot how are you
deciding who's getting the shot where
will it be distributed
ready set go please sir well gail look
we're thrilled to be here today because
this really
culminates more than 13 months of
incredible hard work on the part of our
physicians our scientists our engineers
and the fact that we got the thumbs up
from the fda and the cdc
is just going to have such an important
impact for patients and healthcare
systems around the world
we're shipping as we speak we expect to
have almost 4 million doses out within
the next 24 to 48 hours
where is it going alex where's it going
and who's going to get it
well it's it's it's going to the u.s
government and ultimately they're
deciding they're working with the states
you know as we speak to try to get them
out to the communities but
you know we think the knowing that we've
got a safe and effective
single shot option uh that doesn't
require extensive
refrigeration should help that
distribution that kind of bottleneck
that we've been seeing significantly
in the coming weeks and months alex how
soon do you think
it will be before you have more supply
available
well we're on track to deliver as i said
four million within the next couple of
days
20 million by the month of march and
we'll have a hundred million doses
between now and the end of june and
again what's really important to
remember is that's
a hundred million people by the end of
june can have
one shot and and be done and uh and so
we think that uh
the convenience the the ease of
logistics that that's going to represent
will be significant not only for our
country but frankly for people around
the world
i've heard that people over the age of
18 are eligible
is that true that's true in this initial
round our indication is 18 and older
but look we're already starting on
studies for people that
are between the age of 12 and 18. we're
looking at starting trials even in
younger patients
and pregnant women uh because we realize
we need to generate that kind of
information so that
so people can have the trust and
confidence for it to be used and
we're very confident that over the
course of 2021 we'll have that
data available how effective is the
johnson johnson vaccine against the new
variants that we're hearing about that
are spreading so quickly
well it's a really important question
because when we conducted our clinical
trials on our vaccine
it was during the months of basically
september 2020 to january 2021
when the incidence rate was at really
its highest levels that we've seen thus
far
the second thing is we conducted it
around the world so about forty percent
of our patients were in the united
states
another forty percent were in latin
america and about fifteen percent were
in south africa
over ninety percent of whom had the
south african variant
so whether it was the south african
variant that we know is particularly
challenging with the p2 variant
in brazil our vaccine showed 85
effectiveness in severe disease and it
kept all the patients
out of the hospital and from dying and
so again even in these most
challenging areas during the highest
incidence rate
we're seeing these kind of results with
a single shot
and it's again it's going to be really
important for people to get a shot as
soon as they possibly can
i know and all the experts say whatever
shot you can get please take whatever is
available but why is it okay alex to
just get
one shot with your vaccine and the
others need two
well gail there's a lot of science
behind that it's a science
exactly you know and they spent years
developing that
uh and so to get the the right balance
of effectiveness of safety of dosing and
all those combinations
has put us in this position now where we
can achieve those kind of
results on a single dose alex gorsky ceo
of johnson johnson thank you
and thanks for the work that your
company has done to get us another
vaccine bravo